you know this was me five years ago and
it's still me but I confess I'm a
waistline watcher from way back
well that's enough for today now for a
lively lift ice-cold coca-cola
there's no waistline worried with coke
you know actually this individual sized
bottle has no more calories than half a
grapefruit I really believe in that I'm
gonna poke that boy honey you want to
join you lose weight right you talk
about healthy living right do you want
to include coconut smoothies did you all
believe in what they both said was that
pushy a little sleazy a little yucky and
what I was trying to do are trying to
sell for folk to you both
a recent survey asked about objectives
to define sales and salesmanship and
these are the words that came up if
sales bad or are the techniques that are
used to sell bad and why are they right
this is what we want to talk to you
about
I must confess I have a certain
relationship with tobacco
I used to manufacture them in the past
as well when John Wayne says that not a
single case of throat irritation and
when you also mentioned you do smoking
nah I don't believe it and let me tell
you as a subject authority
subject-matter expert
it's a lie when my child looks at a big
mark in McDonald's he wants to have it
when I look at it it looks very juicy
and very big when you go to a McDonald
and buy one it looks like that
my kid loves it he still has it not
because it's pink but because it's big
man maybe selling him
a big mark requires a different strategy
and this has not only happened in the
past we every day even now we see this
technique being applied over and over
again Sprint tried to talk about how
fast their network is and used
subliminal messaging in the form of a US
map fully colored to talk about coverage
guess what happened whereas in used
Ricky Chavez and basically called
they're called their lie upfront what
happened there they are selling
everybody is selling but what are you
selling should you be selling what you
really give to the customer or should
you be selling because you know what it
looks very catchy trust me in this day
and age with information literally to
beginners it's not gonna work so today
what we are going to talk to you about
is authentic selling we are going to
talk about what isn't it in authenticity
we are going to talk about why it is a
problem and we are going to talk about
how you can be more authentic and how
you can use authentic selling on a
broader scale so let's unpack what we
mean when we talk about inauthentic
selling
we've all been subject to very generic
selling strategies so a lot of companies
will sell this the same way they sell to
me the same way the sell to Mike or Toby
know they will sell us the same message
with through the same channels in the
same manner and as customers we want
more so what they'll do is they'll throw
in some incomprehensible jargon that we
don't understand
second selling has become very linear
think of the traditional car salesperson
so I know what I want when I go into our
car dealership well so does he
he needs his commission he needs his
bonus or he needs his recognition from
his peers so when I walk in he's going
to tell me what will get him
he wants not what I want so it's not a
dialogue it's very linear it's all about
him it's not about me and we want more
we're more deserving of that as
consumers so we need to think about how
can we build relationships between the
people we're selling to and the custom
between the people who are selling to
and the customers themselves
and then thirdly selling has become very
intrusive so I don't know about you but
every Monday morning I get this phone
call at 6 a.m. from this credit card
company that's selling me 0% APR on a
credit card that I don't own and the
thing is it's not just credit card it's
not just phone calls that are happening
are in boxes of for our mailboxes our
phone with all these promotional
messages selling as things that we don't
need all the time and we're tired we
can't do you know they need to find
another way to engage us that makes us
actually want to engage with them in a
productive manner and not just spam us
and lastly it which Ali mentioned
earlier traditional selling strategies
have become very insincere if you see
I'll give you a chance to read this and
we live in a world where we all have
access to information we can all log on
to the internet we can read customer
reviews we can tweet and yet companies
are still lying to us they still want us
to buy what they're selling to us and we
with a good thing now is that consumers
we now have a voice we can now call them
out when they're untruthful and people
are starting to do that so Loft is this
trendy female apparel company and here
they were launching their new favorite
their favorite new pants and consumers
weren't happy so they were launching
their new favorite pants and well they
put it up and they put these 5 4 5 feet
10 models and then their customers
called them out they said well we don't
look like that
those products don't appeal
us and we that their customers couldn't
relate to the products that they were
selling to them so the Internet has
given us a voice that we can now use to
call companies out when they're being
inauthentic an authenticity is not just
a buzzword when as when we ask the baby
boomers generation they placed more
value on a strong brand than they did on
authenticity and well with Millennials
we actually value authenticity more than
we values more than we value strong
brands so we're not it's just not a
buzzword that we're using it's actually
relevant it's driving competitive it's
driving consumer behavior and it can be
a source of competitive advantage well
tessina Lee had talked to you about why
it's so important to bring authenticity
to selling and more broadly to
communication but how do we do it
throughout this course we've learned
some great tips and JD is a great
communicator but I know that if I copy
the exact everything single thing that
JD does I would probably appear quite
fake and even pretentious because it
just wouldn't be me anymore so instead
of telling you what to do we want to
encourage you adopt change your mindset
around communication and encourage you
to tap into these four basic impulses to
be open to connect be passionate and to
listen people sometimes appear as
inauthentic or maybe even untrustworthy
when they're too rehearsed we have this
big presentation large intimidating
audience which I can strange relate to
right now of ours of course you're going
to come up with some script and you're
gonna stick to it because you're nervous
about saying something wrong but you
didn't change your mindset to become
more open if you imagine that you're
presenting to someone that you really
care about someone you trust like a
friend or a family member that way
you'll be more relaxed and you also be
more honest and genuine because you care
about your friend and you also care less
about how they judge you in fact
you can even start by practicing or
crafting your message with this person
in mind
my biggest fear when presenting it is to
look at the audience and see bored faces
and I'm gonna assume that everyone who's
not looking at me right now is writing
some great feedback thank you very much
but really for a lot of presenters they
don't even think about engaging with
their audience until the end of the
presentation the Q&A and you can change
that if you change your mindset and
think more about connecting with your
audience think imagine that you have
this desperate need to connect with your
audience every single minute
imagine that you're dealing with a child
who is bored and ignoring you but whose
attention you desperately need and you
just need to engage them and you thought
that you will think more about
connecting with your audience earlier we
showed you a picture of a burger that's
perfect looking but actually this
picture right here is appealing to me so
much more because I'm actually sensing
this passion and satisfaction of murder
and meat juices coming out I want to be
this guy right now
all right so remember to bring out the
underlying emotion of what you wanna say
because we're all going to connect
better to this feeling of hunger or the
munchies than any food item and I think
this would work even if I'm at a vegan
conference right now finally a lot of
times are they deliver a pitch we're not
even thinking about the audience
reaction we're not looking at people so
I don't know are you excited nervous
thinking about your own for sensation
and trying to understand what how they
feel and that way you can adopt your
message to their needs and emotions and
become better at selling and also
instead of talking over and over again
so hey I want to hear great thanks yeah
so this is all well and good but I think
it brings up the question why should any
of us care about this right one in nine
Americans are actively involved in
selling I think there are about forty
five students right now that means maybe
five of us are gonna actively be using
this in our day to day lives right that
might be the case in in practical terms
but in reality every single person in
this room is a Salesman everything you
do every single interaction that you
have you're selling something you're
selling yourself you're selling your
ideas you're selling your value and your
potential to everyone that you talk to
and every person that sees you
we do this in work all the time I was
gonna give Eric a great shout out
unfortunately he's not here but he gave
us a great presentation on LinkedIn on
Monday and talked about how we sell
ourselves in LinkedIn and that's just
the first step to selling ourselves and
work we sell ourselves in our resume and
our interviews our first day on the job
eating lunch with our co-workers know
how we speak up in meetings how we hold
ourselves in meetings every single time
we do these things it's an opportunity
for us to sell ourselves as someone that
people are looking at for a promotion
people that sell yourselves as someone
that you want on your team when there's
a big project coming up at the office we
also sell ourselves in our personal
lives all the time and Rajon as well is
in here but he told us about selling
ourselves on tinder and the thousands of
people he's trying to sell himself to
every single day that's just it's not
just that you know you're selling
yourself when you go out on a date
you're selling yourself when you meet
your potential partners parents or their
friends or really just when you're
interacting with front
the basis and reminding them that you're
someone that they want to have in their
lives on a regular basis all these are
opportunities for us to sell ourselves
and to improve our prospects moving
forward and the sales are not something
that are going to be occur by our choice
or not by the choice to do it or not to
do it there's something that happened
naturally and we can ignore that fact or
we can embrace it and try to use this
opportunity to sell ourselves
authentically I want to talk really
quickly about the person who I think
it's the most authentic salesman in
America today so close things out and
Burt I know I you told me not to do
politics I'm a kind of a presentation
but I'm almost made it through Donald
Trump
it wouldn't be authentic if I didn't
everyone was amazed when Donald Trump
roast in the polls last summer and
political scientists couldn't figure out
what it was and they asked voters
Republican voters is he most closely
aligned with your ideals they said no
he's not most closely aligned with our
deals is he the most conservative Canada
no it's not the most Conservative
candidate is he the most qualified no
not the most qualified maybe the most
trustworthy no he's not the most
trustworthy either the one poll question
that voters almost unanimously said
Donald Trump was the leading Republican
candidate in is does he believe what he
says not is he being honest but does he
believe what he said Benjamin
in the way he communicates with his
audience and that's why he's one boat
away from the presidency right now
because he's put himself out there is an
authentic figure and he's presented
himself authentically